nothing's gonna go back to the way that
it was hold on to your wallets purses
and fanny packs people there's a bunch
of new streaming services coming and
they're backed by some serious star
power what exactly will these streaming
or is mean for giants like Netflix
Amazon and Hulu and for our pockets well
we're about to tell you right now on the
new Ron tomato show the ketchup the
first stop and probably the one that has
Netflix sweating bullets
is Disney Plus it will launch on
November 12th of this year at $7 per
month or $70 a year which is what my dad
spends on a porterhouse steak and if the
price of a steak doesn't tickle your
fancy does he just announced that
Avengers endgame will hit the surface
about a month after the launch to help
entice new customers let's hope that
deleted scene with the Avengers honoring
Tony makes it in there too because the
movie was already three hours long why
delete it this is gonna work Steve I
know it is and on top of the highest
grossing movie of all time
Disney Plus will eventually offer
original series that includes Avengers
spin-offs like the Falcon in the Winter
Soldier Hawkeye
Loki and Wanda vision along with the Jon
Favreau directed series the mandalorian
set in the Star Wars universe and I'm
just wondering just Jon Favreau get any
sleep I want to do about this job the
service will also feature a live-action
Lady and the [ __ ]
sister act 3 a Monsters Inc spinoff
series and so much more and let's not
forget that with Disney's recent
purchase of 21st Century Fox movie
franchises like Avatar Deadpool and
x-men Plus TV shows like The Simpsons
will be available right alongside the
Marvel Star Wars and classic Disney
animated options kind of feels like
we've all won a Super Bowl
also joining in on the streaming fun
this fall will be Apple TV Plus now
while the cost is still unclear for this
one it will be armed with a variety of
original programming that includes a
reboot of Steven Spielberg's 1980 series
Amazing Stories a drama about a morning
talk show starring Jennifer Aniston and
Reese Witherspoon an untitled series
from la-la-land director Damien Chazelle
a thriller from M night Shyamalan and a
series of documentaries from Oprah so it
kind of feels like we're on the episode
where she gives out all those cars you
got a show you get a show you get a show
[Applause]
and stretch your paycheck out even more
the AT&T owned Warner Media has also
announced its new streaming service
it's called HBO max and it's coming in
the spring of next year
no word on costs for this one yet either
but experts think it will be somewhere
into 17 dollars per month range along
with everything that comes with HBO the
surface will be anchored by classic
shows like friends and The Fresh Prince
of bel-air
as far as original programming goes it
has inked deals with Reese Witherspoon
to produce two films Anna Kendrick will
star in and co-produced a 10 episode
romantic comedy series the 80s classic
gremlins will become an animated series
Kaley Cuoco will star in an hour-long
series based on the popular novel the
flight attendant oh and there's gonna be
a Gossip Girl reboot because xoxo why
not you couldn't ask for a better
rebound to go along with this
subscription-based streaming services on
the way are the free advertising based
services so joining the likes of the
roku channel sony crackle and the new
IMDB TV will be NBCUniversal x' dip into
the streaming world the yet-to-be-named
service is coming in April of next year
and will lean heavily on acquired
content to start and more importantly
starting in 2021 it's where you'll need
to go if you want a little Michael Scott
in your life they should just call this
service Dunder Mifflin come on man
believe in something and it's worth
noting that YouTube premium seems to be
retreating from the paid subscription
model with the video platform now
offering its originals free with ads 399
my favorite price but if shorter form
content is
or your thing there's good news for you
as well because former Disney and
DreamWorks Animation bigwig Jeffrey
Katzenberg is coming in hot next April
with the short form startup kwibi now
kwibi will cost between $4.99 and $7.99
per month feature videos between 7 and
10 minutes in length and already has
content on the way from names like
Steven Spielberg Steven Soderbergh and
Anna Kendrick so what does this mean for
the current big dogs like Netflix Amazon
Hulu and CBS all access us which all
continue to roll out new star powered
content well with Hulu and CBS plans
starting at $6 a month
and Amazon Prime membership breaking
down to $13 a month Netflix recently
raising its standard package to $12.99
per month plus the wave of new services
all coming our way you're looking at
somewhere around $75 a month for all
that combined now I'm no mathematician
but compare that to the average of $50
per month that most people are paying
for cable and you're basically back at
just more expensive cable I'm gonna have
to get a second job just to watch TV
well a new Hollywood Reporter morning
console poll found that Americans only
want to pay twenty one dollars for all
of their streaming services combined and
while that number seems oddly specific
it also means that people will most
likely be picking and choosing just a
couple services based on which stars
franchises and classics that they like
the most and sending the rest downstream
by Felicia
all right it's time to kick it over to
you guys now which new services are you
most excited for how will you decide
which ones to get do you have a massive
amount of anxiety now and should at the
office just be public domain let us know
all your thoughts in the comment section
and tell us what other stories you'd
like to see us cover and for all the
latest streaming news head on over to
Ryan Tomatoes calm thanks for watching
our new show the ketchup where we
explore with the latest news for movies
and TV
as always I'm ass press and I'll see you
guys next time
[Music]